the way i think about trying to build up
resilience uh you know physically or
mentally or otherwise i like to call it
limbic friction because i think it
captures the concept which is that you
know we always hear about resilience it
makes it sound like oh you know under
stress where everything's coming at you
you're gonna stay calm it mostly has to
do with how much limbic friction there
is how much you're being pulled to some
source that source could be internal if
i have if i have pain physical pain in
my body i'm going to be much more
enteroceptive than i am extra receptive
you could be talking to me and i'm just
going to be thinking about the pain it's
very hard what i think it can be useful
for people is to start developing an
awareness when i wake up am i mostly in
a mode of interoception or extraoception
when i work well what does working well
look like from the perspective of
autonomic arousal how alert or calm am i
what kind of balance between internal
focus and external focus is there and to
sort of watch this process throughout
the day so i like the coffee shop
example because the prefrontal cortex
through top-down mechanisms has to
suppress that and say no we're not going
to respond to the banging of the coffee
cups behind me or i'm going to keep
focusing that's pure top-down control so
limbic friction is high in that
environment you put yourself into a high
limbic friction environment meaning that
the prefrontal cortex has to work really
hard but there's another side to limbic
friction too which is when you're very
sleepy there's nothing incoming it can
be completely silent and it's hard to
engage and focus because you're drifting
off you're getting sleepy so their
limbic friction is high but for the
opposite reason autonomic arousal is too
low so they're turning on netflix in the
background or looping a song might boost
your level of alertness that will allow
top down control to be exactly the sweet
spot you want it it's all about how we
feel inside relative to what's going on
on the outside i guess one way you could
envision it spatially is i like to think
about it kind of like a glass barbell
where one sphere of perception and
attention can be on what's going on with
me and one sphere of attention can be in
what's going on with you or something
else in the room or in my environment
this barbell isn't rigid it's not really
glass so imagine that this thing can
contort the size of the the globes at
the end of this barbell can get bigger
or smaller so let's say i close my eyes
and i bring all my experience into
what's going on through interoception
internally now it's as if i've got two
orbs of perception just on my internal
state but i can also do the opposite and
bring to both orbs of perception outside
me i'm not thinking about my heart rate
or my breathing i'm just thinking about
something i see and what you'll start to
realize as you kind of use this spatial
model is that two things one is that
it's very dynamic and that the more
relaxed we are the more these two orbs
of attention the two ends of the barbell
can move around freely
the more alert we are the more rigid
they're going to be tethered in place
and that was designed so that if i have
a threat in my environment
it's tethered to that threat if
something's coming to attack me i'm not
gonna be like oh my breathing cadence is
a little bit quick that's not how it
works why because both orbs are linked
to that threat and so my behavior is now
actually being driven by something
external even though i think it's
internal they're only really three
things that neurons do they're either
sensory neurons they're motor neurons or
they're modulating things
and the models of attention and
perception that we have now 2020 tell us
that we've got interoception and
exteroception they're strongly modulated
by levels of autonomic arousal and that
if we want to form the optimal
relationship to some task or some
pressure or something whether or not
it's sleep an impending threat or coding
we need to adjust our internal
space-time relationship with the
external space-time relationship